Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 3rd,
2014 how you,
how you doing?
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying to get comfortable.
Here is what's going on.
I'm in a,
I'm actually doing this,
my podcast in a studio,
which I never do.
I always do it at home,
laying in my fucking underwear.
Right now I'm in a studio,
the all new,
all things comedy network,
podcast studios.
I'm one of the first guys over here to do a do my podcast that I have to tell
you.
It's a wonderful experience so far and I already know what some of you assholes
are going to say.
Now that I've given that information that I'm not doing my podcast lying down,
you go,
dude,
you're funnier when you're not seated.
You to sit there and break my balls about that.
I don't give a shit.
Go ahead and do it because by the time you give me shit,
this thing is already recorded.
What the fuck do I care?
I've gotten all of my life.
I'm down the street having a snow cone,
you know,
that's the life I'm living.
Huh?
When do that you're not about this life hit the white mainstream.
If I hear one more white person fucking say that like they,
that Scott's going to be the next um,
African American,
uh,
expression that they're going to have like old white grandmother sang and
fucking cheesy comics.
Sorry.
Cheesy comedies.
I,
when I sipped it,
that does sound like a fart there.
I just sip some water there.
Um,
you're not about this life.
Oh Shit.
The old white lady shed the thing.
The young black kids say if only she could give the finger and there was an
orangutan,
you'd have yourself self a comedy.
Um,
all right.
So how the,
how the hell are you idol?
I had a long ass frigging week,
week and weekend.
Uh,
ended up going to a wedding.
You guys like going to those things?
You don't went to weddings?
You know,
I loved about this wedding.
There was no dancing.
Okay?
And when you as white as me,
that is a very enjoyable moment.
You know what I mean?
Oh my God,
this is going to be booze and there's going to be no dancing and you're going to
have a quick beautiful ceremony.
Uh,
is there any way I can retroactively pay for this,
this beautiful service?
It was tremendous.
It's one of the best weddings I've been to.
So I want to thank those two people who got married for having such a wonderful,
beautiful,
yet quick service.
That's what you want,
by the way,
when you get married,
all you people out there fucking torture and everyone with you.
Long ass ceremonies,
you know,
like,
yeah,
the King and Queen of uh,
one of those stupid countries with the pasty people over there in Europe.
Who else has a king and Queen Leftover in Europe,
England.
They like the Wrigley Field of governments over there.
Right?
And they got these fucking jerk offs who just won't stop fucking each other
because they got the same kind of bloodline.
So then all of them sort of in a roundabout way look like the English version of
Eli and Peyton manning.
You know,
that's the deal dude.
Like when,
when you,
okay,
or at least when you go to procreate,
you got to get outside your circle,
get you got to run a post pattern,
get off your block.
You know what I mean?
You can't start banging the girl next door.
She's right there.
She smelled your toast and all the shit you are eating.
I'm telling you,
you're going to get like a fuck.
I don't know if you're going to give all those weird kids,
um,
who never wants to leave the town,
right?
Molly dreams about his driving a fucking truck to plow the snow.
You know,
it was a big thing when I was in Massachusetts,
you know,
getting a fucking state job.
All those guys,
you know,
it's fucked up and angry and on edge and as racist is,
Massachusetts is,
people always goes,
why are they liberal?
Why do they still vote Democrat?
It's because the amount of people there that want to get a state job so they can
lean on a fucking shovel,
a drive,
one of those orange pickup trucks,
like a half a mile an hour in the breakdown lane
Dillard,
you drive in to fast.
Fucking slow it down.
It's just supposed to take all day.
I knew a guy long time ago I worked in a warehouse and he had,
he quit the postal service because he was bored out of his mind.
He was a young kid and he knew somebody and he got in with the post,
uh,
working for the post office and he went out and he did his route and he got,
he was done with it by 11,
and the old timers go,
what the fuck are you doing here?
Get out of here.
Don't come back till four o'clock.
You're going to fuck this whole thing up.
So he went out and he like went to the movies and got like a sandwich and came
back and he just,
because he was raised right,
he couldn't live a life like that right now.
You know what I love it says possibly somebody who works one of those jobs
listing right now.
Yeah.
And I want to,
I want to ask you,
how do you live with yourself?
How do you get up every morning and take an eight hours to do a fucking two hour
job?
How do you do that shit?
You know what I mean?
Do you really feel like you're getting any,
like you're getting away with something?
Just I met,
we'd be just be torture.
Just imagine like whatever.
Just make anything take four times longer than it should.
Right.
Cooking yourself an egg in the morning.
Okay.
Cooking it on low and just sitting there fucking ran the thing being ready in
like three minutes,
12 minutes later there's a fucking fried egg.
That's the worst example ever.
But you know what?
I made step on the gas pedal.
You piece of shit.
Um,
no,
it's awful.
I'm so pro union,
it's ridiculous.
But I feel like so many of the unions literally became,
what the fuck they were fighting and then they just became assholes.
And then the corporations were like,
well,
you know,
fuck you.
Then keep your union and we'll take the factory.
We will move it elsewhere.
Oh,
look at this.
It's a third world country.
Okay.
Are there any laws even down here?
Fuck it.
We'll go back to plain people the way we did before the triangle.
Shirtwaist fire there.
Look at me.
Oh,
who took a double deck?
A tour bus in fucking new.
I did this guy.
All right.
What did I just fucking lean back too far on the chair and I disconnected it.
You know what we,
you know,
it's this a brand new studio,
so we're going to have some glitches.
There was a glitch that's just boom.
Anyway,
so they just fucking,
people were making shirts and when you made shirts back then you had a,
you had a little bit of waste yet.
Shirtwaist
long story short,
somebody threw a fucking cigarette in there.
I don't know what happened.
They didn't have any fire escapes and the God damn doors,
we'll lock that.
Everybody had to like basically jump to their fucking deaths.
And uh,
that was the reference.
It's not a very funny reference,
but it is a reference.
Um,
speaking of what should you guys see that,
uh,
that virgin,
airplane that goes out into space crashed fucking terrifying.
Is that through the God damn the balls to be a test pilot to go up the I,
we designed this thing now on paper this thing should work and then you have to
go up there.
It basically see if it works and then once it works you have to start seeing
what,
how big the f the,
the fucking what the envelope within this thing can perform in,
which basically involves what they,
what the,
you know,
the whole pushing the envelope.
Like whatever.
Just say you flew a helicopter and they said you can't go beyond 102 knots or
else you'd get fucking uh,
retreating blade stall.
Like how do you learn how to do that?
That means some mother fucker has to go 103 nuts,
104 cause you know,
when they say it's 102,
you know,
they,
they still stop it way before,
but it means somebody had to have the balls to just keep pushing that stick
forward.
I mean,
what the what they think standup comics of fucking psychos to be a test pile.
I mean it then you know what's the worst thing about that is what excites you
after that?
Once you're on the fucking ground.
Oh,
you,
I'm so happy you're home.
Look what I did.
I rearranged the furniture here.
This is great.
It just like opens up the room,
don't you think?
Why don't you just stare at me like that when I say thanks.
I'm sorry.
I'm not 30,000 feet off the fucking ground,
but down here holding down the fort for you.
Well,
you're coming from,
Huh?
Did you get another blow job after one of your test flights
and what does he do?
He just stares at it,
right?
Maybe starts laughing like Ray Liotta and Goodfellas
and it fucking lap.
So he's wiping his eye and he goes back out to a rocket ship with Joe Pesi a
doubt.
Fuck.
I'd have people a day.
That's your life then.
You can't relate to anybody anymore.
That's the deal.
Everybody's looking at you like,
what's your fucking problem?
It's like,
what's fucking problem?
I've,
I've been like a,
I went to the moon.
That's my problem now talking to you who uh,
you know,
I went to the Patriots Broncos game and you got your fucking eyebrows up.
Like what you just did was exciting and I'm sorry I'm having a little difficult,
a little difficult time relating to you right now.
You know,
and you know,
his wife has given of Shit.
You have to stop bringing up the fact that you've been to space.
You know that you test pilots,
test pilots,
you test airplanes anyway,
so,
um,
so they got this plane that goes up into space.
I mean,
and they're just going to go try this fucking thing out the balls of those guys.
Unfortunately it didn't fucking work out.
Dude is no fucking way.
Do you realize the amount of fucking jackass is
slash former members of boy bands that are just lining up to pay 200 grand to be
the first fucking jerk off,
absolute fucking jerk off to get on one of those things.
Ct.
Okay.
If he,
if he got 200 grand to do it,
keep it in your pocket.
All right.
Let other people be the test pilot passengers for this fucking thing.
You don't do that.
It's like,
oh,
it's like when,
when like,
like a new fucking iPhone comes out when,
when they came up with that lasik eye surgery,
you know,
and people will get blinded and they will fucking it up cause it was new.
You don't fuck with new technology is all I'm saying.
It's fucking idiot.
I want to go up in space.
You're nuts.
Why would you,
you know what,
I actually got to think here.
What would I rather do?
What would you rather do?
Would you rather risky life going into space or go scuba diving?
To me,
those are the two big,
the two probably most terrifying things I've ever seen in my life.
Oh yeah.
I gotta tell you this weekend,
I fucking,
uh,
when I went to that wedding,
there was a,
I was out in palm desert and um,
state this really cool hotel that had this,
um,
this basically lounge act.
And I don't want to disrespect the person,
but it was a lounge and he was doing his act right.
And,
uh,
you know,
older guys like in his sixties or whatever and he was singing the shit out of
these Frank Sinatra songs.
He was great,
really was great.
And um,
and it was fun watching the older people watch the guy cause in the end he had
all this whole,
this whole patriotic thing when he did like a salute to the troops except it was
real,
you know what I mean?
It's just a different time.
Like these guys are like a,
okay,
well wait a minute.
He was born in 1949 I think I looked him up.
So he would have been 20 in 1969,
I'll fuck daddy's probably the Woodstock generation.
Anytime I see old people like saluting the flag,
I just think they fought in World War II.
I think I watched too many episodes of that.
Ken Burns the warp,
but whatever.
It was a nice thing.
And uh,
the
veterans in the crowd stood up a bunch of old guys and all that.
It was a really nice thing.
But in between,
he was telling these,
uh,
um,
he was a hundred percent Sicilian and he was telling these fucking old old,
old school jokes that of course would bomb and a comedy club within the context
of what he was doing.
They were great.
And uh,
one of the things he said,
he said,
uh,
you know,
I'm a hundred percent Sicilian.
My,
uh,
my birthstone is cement or something like that,
which obviously,
you know,
fucking high old time joke,
but it just reminded me
of a,
one of the worst deaths.
I've actually thought about this.
Like if somebody ever,
uh,
you know,
one of the take you out and you're standing on a fucking boat in cement that's
drying and it's at night and it taken you out into the ocean and they're just
going to toss you fucking overboard.
I would be just standing there weeping,
just going,
just shoot me.
Just fuck.
Yeah,
they big guy.
We can't man the blood splatter.
We've got to get caught.
Well,
can you fucking shoot me as your throw me it.
Just give me a gun,
right as you throw me in,
I'm going to pull the trigger.
Is that all right?
I'll count to 1000 now already be in the water and won't work.
Like what happens is that already medical person out there?
Is it a quick death?
I just can't imagine.
That's your fucking going down waiting for your God damn head to explode
and then you'd want it like somehow like just take a big gulp of water to end it
and uh,
you couldn't,
your body wouldn't let you fuck it.
Oh my God.
You're like,
just kills me about that is you just keep going down and down and down and down.
Okay.
Way Past where all the fucking submarines,
anybody's ever fucking God.
You're just,
you're going to keep going.
Now granted the pressure is gonna fucking kv in at some point,
right?
Just that the fucking weight of that water,
you know,
it'd be worse if your survival instinct kicked in and you kept clearing your
ears as you went down for as long as you fucking could.
You just
like just some futile attempt to just survive.
You keep clearing the fucking air out of your you station tubes,
you know,
see a fucking ear drum stone explode.
Oh Christ.
What a fucking way to go.
And that's all I'd actually zoned out as he was singing.
What is a man?
What has he got?
Damn that himself,
that a shot,
right?
I just kept it the whole time he was singing that
to speak the Whoa t 20 fields.
Right?
I always just picturing going down to the bottom of the ocean and cement shoes.
Not the words of one who deals,
it was like this little Goodfellow
film film was going on in my head.
I mean,
granted,
I was a couple scotches in,
Oh,
you know what?
So,
um,
it was a buddy of mine who got married and I was supposed to get him some sick
guys and I've been so busy with my day job.
Okay.
Um,
writing on the a or sitting in the room pitching
jokes on the soon to be hit animated show in December of 2015 f is for family.
I'm going to hype this fucking show.
I'm going to hype this fucking show for a year.
So you guys better get,
you've got to get ready.
You know what I'm literally doing?
Like when they said this,
you know,
when they hyped it and when it's actually coming out,
it's like how long it takes for a guy on the mass pike
to drive to a pothole fucking a mile away.
MMM.
Anyway,
so I didn't have time to get the cigars right.
So I got to hook up out here to get the old fucking,
uh,
Cubanos there.
And um,
anyways,
this,
uh,
I didn't do it.
So I go out to palm desert and I'm like,
all right,
there's all these old fucking staunch Republicans out here.
They all got money.
Okay.
They all like playing golf.
They like smoking fucking cigars.
I know they got Cuban cigars,
so I just don't go to a smoke shop.
I look for a high end fucking place that actually has a little bit of a lounge
thing,
right.
You know,
fucking wooden Indian outside and Shit,
you know,
all the old school stuff.
So I find one right?
And I walk in there and I'm just like,
hey man,
just,
uh,
it's my buddies,
you know,
uh,
he got married today.
I'm in between the,
actually the wedding ceremony and the after party.
I was supposed to get cigars.
I fucked up.
Can you help me out?
He goes,
yeah,
sure.
Come on in the human door.
So I say to the guy,
hey,
you got any,
you know,
uh,
Monte Cristo or uh,
you know,
party gas,
any,
any fucking,
you know,
basically.
And he goes,
uh,
I go,
you got some Cubans.
He goes,
well,
I got these over here and I go,
you got any Cuban cigars?
And he goes,
killed at set.
Guards are illegal in the United States of America.
Ugh.
It's one of the fucking slap him in the face with a book of matches out.
Really?
Thank you.
Like,
I don't fucking know that
Jesus fucking Christ.
Okay,
well,
maybe because I looked like a cop.
He said it and me.
What the f
heroin is not legal.
What led that?
You know,
I know it isn't.
I'd still like some,
I'm asking you to do an illegal transaction here.
I have cash.
I'm willing to,
I've never fucking been,
and you know,
every place I go to out here,
you just fuck it.
Ask Him.
They have him in the back.
And this is what's funny is
people say,
they say this shit,
right?
They'll go,
uh,
yeah.
You know,
actually or like 99.999 to 99% of the fucking Cuban cigars in this country are
fake.
And you know what?
They're wrong because I've been outside this country and I've smoked him and
they taste the exact same.
And then they're going to say,
well,
you know,
once Castro,
fucking Bluebell,
blah,
blah.
All those companies fucking out of Cuba,
go fuck yourself with your theories.
Okay?
You read an article on one of those websites that have lists.
I don't give a shit.
All I know is that the Cuban cigar that I smoked in Paris,
France tastes the same as the one out here.
Okay?
So whatever it is,
and that thing tastes way better than all of the fucking legal ones.
All those other ones that they say,
oh,
this Davidoff fucking Nicaraguan,
you know,
tastes better.
Don't tested higher than the Cuba ones.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You're still comparing them to compete Cuban cigars and there's a reason for it.
It's just like however you fucking car compares itself to something German or
Italian or whatever,
right?
This is like a Ferrari,
except it's only 40 grand.
You know,
by the way,
I,
uh,
I'm going to talk cars here for a second.
I got to,
um,
what I got to do here.
I got to read some of the advertising for this week.
Those was going to put on his fucking horse shoes here and he's going to read
the advertising.
All right?
Live reads.
Bingo.
Bango.
All right.
What do we got here?
One,
two,
three this week people,
there's only three left.
What,
what?
Say we just knock them all out right here.
All right,
Bob,
who do up,
but it'll put it up.
All right.
Draft Kings.
Everybody listen as I winning huge cash prizes every week@draftkings.com and you
could get your piece of the million dollars being awarded this weekend.
Draft Kings as America's favorite one week fantasy football site one week
fantasy means no seasoned long commitments.
Play whenever you want.
If you've got an injured player,
not a problem at draft kings where it's like a new season every week so you're
never stuck with the same pos player Danny Amendola,
I'm sorry,
I shouldn't have said that.
Pick your team in minutes and you could be on your way to instant cash.
Last year,
one play,
uh,
turned 11 bucks into four grand.
Another one a hundred grand.
His first time ever playing and another player won a million bucks in one day.
Hurry and get a free entry into the Sunday million events.
Sunday billions event this weekend where 1 million bucks in cash prizes is up
for grabs.
This is my bad Howard Cosell.
Call to action head a draft kings.com right now and enter Promo code defense to
play for free.
Draft,
kings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings,
bigger millionaires.
Enter defense for free.
Entry now@draftkingsdotcomdraftkings.com what is it?
Draft kings.com oh shit.
Look who's back.
It's me undies.
Everybody.
Mian ds me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
boop me undies.
Mandy's.
You got to get them for they'll fall.
No more smell.
Lee fucking tanked
something.
Something,
something in your balls are saying.
Oh,
go get yourself some fucking me undies.
Why do I have to read the copy?
I don't know.
All right,
here we go.
90%.
That's the percent of your life that you're in your underwear and your
underwear.
It gets old,
fast,
gross and always gets gross.
It's unbelievable how putting on a great pair of underwear changes your entire
outlook for that day.
That's not a joke.
Uh,
you know that feeling of putting on that ratty old saggy underwear.
I want you to know the feeling of wearing great fitting underwear.
Great looking underwear.
Underwear that cares about your balls.
All right?
You need to know about me undies.
Dotcom.
Me undies has the most comfortable underwear you have ever tried on.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you.
They literally pull moisture away from your skin.
Gross.
Uh,
so you're cool all day long.
Who has sweaty balls?
Who is sweaty balls that isn't walking around working out.
You know,
and I think a lot of guys have sweaty balls and I think me undies is filling a
void here.
So if you're one of those sweaty ball guys,
here's the rest of the copy.
Here's what I love me undies is environmentally friendly.
Well doesn't that depend on what you eat?
You know,
because once you put your skid marks in there,
if you're fucking eating a bunch of processed food,
you know,
it's like when you put rat poison down,
right?
The rat eats sitting in,
the coyote eats the rat and,
and the mountain lion eats the fucking coyote and they all die the same poison.
Is it bill?
I don't think it is.
All right.
The materials they use are sustainably sourced
shit.
Sorry,
I touch the screen.
They're sustainably sourced from the Austrian Alps and they are completely
natural.
They also use a CO2 neutral process with a low carbon footprint.
They save water and energy due to their spun dried fiber process.
You know what?
I might have to try these fucking things.
I got to get a pair.
They have cool styles for both men and women and they all look great.
Check out the photos yourself,
me,
undies,
me undies.
Go get a fucking pair of me undies.com this quality would typically retail for
two times the me undies price.
No retail middlemen means more savings for you.
Here,
I'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn and get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they care Auntie you're that.
You're going to be happy with them or your first pair is free.
If you're not happy with them,
they'll come over there on the wipe the residual moisture off your nuts because
that's the only way you can't be happy with these.
They're actually sending me some sweatpants this week.
I can't wait.
I'm going to try them on and I'm going to tell you about them next week cause
I'm a whore.
I'm here.
I'll help you out.
Go to me undies,
dotcom slash burn and get 20% off your first order of 20% off your order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and right now you'll even get free
shipping in the US and in Canada.
And lastly,
but certainly not leastly stamps.com everybody getting your mail and shipping
can eh,
sorry.
Getting your mail and shipping done can seem like a no win situation situation.
Uh,
going to the post office takes up valuable time.
Leasing a postage meter is expensive with multiyear commitments and hidden fees.
Who the hell wants that?
Luckily,
oh,
freckles here knows a better way.
Go to stamps.com with stamps.com buy and print official US postage for any
letter or package right from your desk using your own computer.
A printer even gets special postage discounts.
You can't find it.
The post office plus stamps.com is more powerful than a postage meter at just a
fraction of the cost.
You can save up to 80% compared to a postage meter and you will avoid those time
consuming trips to the post office.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters and whatever other crap up doin to
whore myself out that week.
Um,
and if I can figure it out.
So can you right now use my last name,
birth for this special offer.
B R no risk trial plus 110 $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up
to $55 in free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
burr.
All right.
All right,
let's talk cause um,
so I've been threatening that I was going to buy a new car.
The old priests is getting old.
The old fucking Prius.
She ain't what she used to be.
Okay.
Actually,
to be honest with you,
only need to do is get a little interior work done.
Just fresh interrupt.
But uh,
you know,
there's a couple of cars out there.
They got my eye on,
one of them was a Mercedes Benz and,
um,
AMG fucking psycho level car,
right?
And a,
the other day yesterday I saw one on the highway.
Is this ever happened to you?
You see your fucking dream car,
you see the car you want to,
when they need drive up and you're like,
I just gotta see what the person looks like that's driving it.
I bet they look like an astronaut fucking test pilot of some shit.
Right?
A war hero.
I do it.
I pulled up along this car.
This guy could not have looked like more of a fucking dirt bag.
He's like in his twenties,
you know,
at age,
just look like a fucking,
I can't even,
I can't explain it because I'll get in trouble,
you know,
and not,
not really by the fucking politically correct police.
Just by,
you know,
this nationality of people like they like if pitbulls became human beings,
um,
it just looked like a fuck.
Like I,
if I haven't had a daughter and this guy showed up at the door,
t t to date her,
I,
I don't know what I would do.
I would do something fucking crazy and then I would start weeping afterwards.
He just looked like the biggest piece of shit ever.
And that was just like,
am I a piece of shit?
I am a piece of shit,
but am I that kind of a piece of shit?
Is that what I'm going to look like?
But then if I get the car,
other people will be,
oh,
that's my dream car.
And they're gonna pull up alongside him.
See fucking Ron Howard driving the thing.
It's going to ruin it for,
I think Mercedes Benz Oughta pay me not to buy one of their cars
or at least give a free tinted window.
Okay.
Package to me.
So it doesn't fucking hurt.
They're hurt their product.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno,
but I'm going to get one for this and this what I'm doing,
I'm waiting right now.
I can get the car but I have to wait till the downstairs is done in my house.
You know,
cause that is a bad fucking move.
You don't want to go out and buy a new car and when people are doing work on
your house,
cause they'll still just think like okay this guy isn't spreading themselves too
thin.
This guy is just bottomless.
All right.
It's not fucking true.
I mean you get,
you can get yourself in any car for like 1500 bucks now signed a god Damn Lisa
on the thing.
They don't give a shit.
They give you fucking eight miles a month.
Your,
it's all good,
right?
You drive home,
you already over the miles,
any,
any fucking jerk.
That's a thing now about cars.
Back in the day when you had to buy him,
you actually had to be able to afford them.
So if somebody came down the street and a Cadillac or Mercedes or something like
that,
you could look at that man and it was a man because those bitches stayed home
back then.
Right?
It was a fucking man.
And you could look at and hold your head high and go,
I wonder who the fuck he robbed to get that Goddamn car?
What did he do?
You know,
that's the great thing about being an entertainer is people,
you know,
you gotta admit,
entertainers,
we earned our money.
We started out in the fucking lounges,
you know,
um,
I'm totally doing this,
lobbing it over the net.
So you fucking cunt out there can actually rip me apart and say that I don't
deserve it.
Um,
no,
I think I'm a,
I just gotta get through this fucking built.
Once they just finished this fucking thing,
it's almost done.
People,
they literally,
they put in the hardwood floors.
Okay,
I have floors downstairs now they're putting a tile in and the fucking laundry
room that's going to be done.
Everything's going to fucking make sense.
Do you know my fucking Washer and dryer were in a closet off of my kitchen.
Does that make any fucking sense?
Put them downstairs now we turned the laundry room upstairs into a walk in
pantry.
All right,
so I can resell it someday because I,
one thing I've learned about women,
they like being able to walk into something where they can put a bunch of shit.
You know,
they don't want a closet.
They want to walk into the closet.
Oh my God.
Look at them.
I couldn't walk in and put all my stuff here.
They were in a kitchen.
They liked the kitchen.
But if they can walk into a Pantry,
I could put the flower over here and a mic thorough.
I've been there.
I can walk into it.
That's what you want to do.
Like if I was still a single man,
I would build like some sort of walk in closet,
like a mini one,
like leading to my Dick.
Right.
And then you just go out to the,
actually it didn't Justin Timberlake through that when he put his,
put his dick in a box.
Okay.
Gosh,
you know,
not every idea is going to be original.
Um,
anyways,
so anyway,
I can I can I give you guys a little bit of promotion here at the all things
comedy network?
That was a eight.
It's a podcast network that I,
um,
I started with a Al Madrigal and a couple other fellers and,
it's basically a,
you know,
okay.
It's basically owned and operated by standup comics.
And we don't own anybody's podcasts.
We don't try to fuck anybody out of money.
All right?
But things,
things do cost money.
So we're having this here.
All things comedy,
$5 fundraisers starts today.
All right?
Our goal is to outfit the new all things comedy studio in Hollywood with the
professional quality a v equipment.
Uh,
go to tube,
start.com buy a sticker that says I support all things comedy for five bucks,
shipping included the all things comedy live podcast number four,
by the way,
is available today on iTunes.
Subscribe rate and review it.
This episode features,
uh,
John Heffron Jackie.
Okay.
Because Shane,
I'm the worst reader ever.
Dean del Rey,
myself,
Al Madrigal and Philippe s Barraza uh,
you gotta listen to him.
Did I say his name right?
As far as Esparza,
I'm the fucking worst.
Um,
and you know what,
in such a fucking crime that I didn't say his name correctly cause he had the
best goddamn stories I've ever heard.
You've got to listen to it.
Um,
such a white guy from the fucking east coast.
I can't anything remotely Latino.
I can't even pronounce it.
Um,
that's embarrassing of listen to all just fucking comedy too.
What a piece of shit I am.
Anyways,
check it out.
It's going to be on iTunes.
Um,
all right,
let's get back to the podcast.
Can we talk a little football?
What showed up?
What did the boot it up?
Um,
yeah,
I'm not going to brag about the Patriots beat and the Broncos.
I'm not going to do that.
I'm not going to act like,
you know,
Tom Brady is better than fucking eat.
Uh,
Peyton manning.
I'm not going to do that shit.
I'm not going to do that.
All right.
I,
you know,
the record speaks for itself.
Head to head match ups.
I hate when people do that
well know always seven to two against the lifetime.
Well I guess that means he's a better quarterback.
I think it all comes down to a,
you know,
when you had your opportunities,
what did you deal with them all right.
That's basically what it is because everything else is,
you got everybody else on the fucking field.
You know,
people always come up with a reason to blame it on the biggest guy and I don't
think that's necessarily fair.
All right.
Although that picks six he threw against the saints was his fault.
I'll give him shit on that one.
And,
but I also think Brady should have hit west welcome guy was fucking wide open
through to the back shoulder.
Welker OCI should've caught it.
Just a fucking shame.
And then what happened?
Next thing you know Eli,
okay,
the fucking middle child ends up with more rings and Peyton figure that one out.
You know?
But the thing about Eli that you got to love about that guy is as much as he
looks like he always has a cold,
the bigger the game,
the better he plays.
So I fucking love that guy.
Despite the fact he kiss team kicked,
my team's asked twice in the Superbowl.
But you know what,
when you've won three others,
I guess of,
okay.
You don't realize that the Patriots are actually,
you have been in.
MMM,
I think more super bowls.
I mean,
we've been in,
let's see,
we lost to the bears.
We lost to the packers who beat the rams.
We beat the,
uh,
the panthers.
We'd beat the eagles.
We also have giant swaths of the giants.
That's seven.
Oh,
record is three and four.
I think the cowboys had been in the most super bowls.
What's their deal?
They lost to the colts.
Then they beat Miami.
Right.
So those were two
in Miami.
Beat the Redskins and then Steelers beat the cowboys and the cowboys beat the
Broncos.
Then Steelers beat the cowboys.
So that's five.
They'd been in eight,
and then they beat the bills twice and then they beat the Steelers.
So they've been an eight pages have been seven Superbowls.
How the fuck did that happen?
The goddamn door doormats to the league,
uh,
played in that high school football stadium.
Unbelievable.
But,
um,
yeah,
I'm not going to brag about shit.
Uh,
you know,
we also let up 21 points.
We still suck against the run and it's also a regular season game and all that
type of shit.
So like I said,
I'm not gonna really fucking Brag about that.
Um,
um,
I am happy that we won and all that type of shit.
Uh,
but I gotta be honest with you,
I have no idea who the best team is right now.
Um,
I mean,
can,
somebody explained to me the San Diego charges,
but the fuck is that like,
if you bet on football this year,
you're out of your mind at this point.
You should just cut your losses and go home 37 and nothing against the dolphins,
you know?
No,
no disrespect to the dolphins,
but the fucking dolphins,
37 and nothing.
I missed the whole game,
so I should just shut up
the hell up.
I was at that stupid,
not stupid if it,
and I was doing that event thing,
uh,
as a sports fan in me saying that it was stupid.
Um,
boy,
whatever.
So I haven't,
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't know who shot.
I don't know who's not.
I don't know who's good.
I really don't.
And I'm,
but the Patriots,
look how the Patriots look every year to me,
um,
since we stopped Lu,
uh,
winning Superbowls.
So,
you know,
I think we're,
once again,
I love that that were somehow number one against the pass.
That's great.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
it'd be nice if we could have been at least seventh against the run as opposed
to like dead last.
I'm quoting somebody from last week.
I might be wrong about that,
but,
uh,
you know,
so whatever.
I hope,
I hope I'm,
yeah,
whatever.
I know we're going to make the play offs obviously,
cause I division fucking stinks.
And,
um,
I don't know what about that.
Jet's Jesus fucking Christ one an eight.
Thank God for that aid is,
are they,
they'd have the worst team in the league.
Unbelievable.
That's how you right now,
you know he's going to be a fucking bargain to pick up his rex Ryan when they
fire that guy because that guy is a good coach.
I don't like that.
He talks shit,
disrespects other fucking teams and he does.
And it's comes from a place of insecurity,
I think.
And then he tried.
Yeah.
No,
you can't get back to you.
Shut the fuck up.
You ran your mile 20.
You had a good team.
Now your team stinks.
So now you're,
now you're not talking.
So maybe he is a good guy.
Maybe did learn his lesson.
I'm going to wait for rex Ryan to have another good team and if he doesn't talk
shit,
then I'll be like,
all right.
He kind of learned a lesson then,
but I think most of the reason why he's kept his mouth shut is because his team
has stunk.
However,
um,
I will say this,
that
that team is not his fault.
Uh,
they,
uh,
you got to get rid of that GM,
you know,
coach is only as good as the is.
I sound like one of those stupid analysts on fucking ESPN,
but it's true.
The Guy,
he doesn't have anybody and Gino Smith's,
from what I heard was the dead gms.
That was his big fucking pick.
You know,
what are you supposed to do?
So,
uh,
whatever.
So he's going to get blamed,
he's going to get fired,
the jams going to get fired and then someone's going to pick up rex Ryan and I
think,
you know,
if he gets,
if he gets with the right Gm,
I think,
you know,
that guy took the jets to like within two plays.
Okay.
Uh,
or one drive I should say,
of getting to the Superbowl.
The fucking jets.
Okay.
That's an accomplishment in itself,
you know,
so
I dunno,
it's weird.
I used to.
I remember for the longest time I used to wish I was switched to jets would lose
and I fucking hated Rex Ryan cause he was talking all that shit and I wanted to
see the guy flame out exactly what the fuck's happening and now it's happening.
And I feel bad for the guy because I feel like a,
what's going on is not his fault.
Okay.
I wanted them to lose with the fucking players that he picked cause he talked
all that fucking shit.
You know,
we're going to win a suit,
blow with the best fucking tee with it's fucking league.
All of that Shit just drove me up the Goddamn wall.
But now it's,
now it's how I can't root for a guy to lose his job.
Okay.
Can I,
yeah.
Jesus.
I Dunno.
Um,
anyways,
what,
how,
how much,
how much time have I done here,
by the way,
Mike?
Well,
we started over,
didn't we?
Or what this is,
this is the real time.
37 minutes.
All right.
I'm 37 minutes in.
Uh,
all right,
what the fuck else am I going to talk about?
Oh,
I did a,
I did a benefit benefit,
uh,
for pit bulls last night.
It's one of my favorite benefits of the year cause I absolutely fucking love
dogs.
And I also showed up and
there's all these pitfalls there that need to be adopted and stuff and uh,
uh,
the best,
the best fucking look like if you drew a dog's face,
that's what a pit bull fit.
You know what their face looks like.
That is just a fucking dog.
So I went over there and there's all these poor dogs that had their fucking ears
clipped and shit and you know,
they went through all of this God damn pain and they just sitting there,
you know,
they're looking scary cause if fucking ears are all cut up and shit,
I was so,
I go over to pet this one.
Right?
Okay.
Great fucking dog.
It's one of those dogs.
We,
you start petting it.
It like leads into you.
It puts all its weight on you.
And I wasn't prepared for that.
And I squatted down like a catcher to pet this thing and it just fucking leaned
into me and actually knocked me over like a fucking asshole.
But uh,
oh,
it was crazy.
They had puppies there.
You know,
if my dog wasn't such a psycho and wouldn't try to fight another dog,
if I brought it in,
I would own three of them.
So I just got to ride it out with the crazy dog that I loved.
Now give her the best life possible.
Um,
but when a,
that chapter is over,
I'm going to get a,
I'm going to get a blue nose,
a red nose.
I'm going to get an all white one and I'm going to get a black one.
I'm going to have four of them.
And even then that won't be enough.
That's how much I fucking love that breed of dog.
So it was a,
it was a fucking great time going over there and doing the show.
I actually,
I did two shows and the first show went great.
The second show,
I don't know what happened.
I think I went out and I went out too hard.
There was a comic in the room that I wanted to impress a comic that I like to
when I was starting out.
Now he's still like,
I'm obviously,
but uh,
I tried to fuck it.
That's,
I swear to God,
nothing will humble you like fucking standup comedy every time you think he got
it down,
you know,
like,
ah,
I got this fucking figured out.
What ends up happening?
You go up there and yeah,
I didn't eat my balls,
but uh,
I definitely,
uh,
I,
my munched on them a little bit.
Yeah.
Okay.
I swear to God,
I thought,
I said,
I thought he said it the same funny way I went up there and I said,
you know what?
Okay,
I just hope that when it's all said and done,
all the money we raise here tonight,
some of it trickles actually trickles down.
Okay.
To some,
to the dogs or something like that.
Cause you know,
all these,
half of these fucking,
these Goddamn uh,
charities are total scams just as far as like,
uh,
you know,
the,
the amount of money that goes towards whatever the hell they're trying to stop
versus what they line their pockets with.
I mean it is a shame.
It's a scam.
Somebody sent me something where,
you know,
the amount of charities out there that they named their charity,
that almost sounds like the legitimate charity,
you know,
like that,
um,
that coming to America and said,
and Mcdonald's,
it's Mcdowell's they do that and these fucking pieces of shit.
We'll just put a picture of a starving kid or something like that.
And then you feel bad.
You dropped some change and there were a couple bucks and they just keep it and
they go out and they get a house.
All right.
We had another glitch with some of the why is here the fuck was I talking about?
It'll get better people,
it'll get better if you get down there,
get your all things comedy,
$5 fundraiser stickers.
Um,
we even have a website.
Okay.
Mike,
do we even have a website?
Whether it was supposed to tell these people to get these fucking stickers there
to start.com.
Oh right there.
Go to [inaudible] dot com if you'd like,
they stop hearing delays in this podcast now,
whatever.
We'll figure it out.
Anyway.
So these cons,
they start a,
um,
what do you call a charity
and they name it like another charity that's actually legitimate.
And then they put some,
you know,
sad puppies face or a how to fuck knows what and then they make a bunch of
money.
Next thing you know,
they've got a big house sitting by a pool and they don't feel one ounce of guilt
there.
Absolutely.
You know,
what would happened to these people if they actually did something like that.
And then Singapore,
you know,
where it's illegal to spit gum
on the sidewalk.
I can't imagine the caning that these people would get and they would fucking
deserve it too,
is horrific as a caning video is.
Um,
I actually have a theory people,
oh Billy gossip has coming with the theory.
I've noticed this year,
you know,
a lot of stuff came out about a certain campaign that a,
that was raising awareness that made everybody wear the,
uh,
well,
it's not quite a Magenta,
pink,
the pink campaign.
A lot of shit came out about that.
A lot of unsavory floating.
She had old woody about that campaign and about how much money was being raised
and how much was actually being appropriated toward actually finding a fucking
cure for breast cancer and how much was going into a new tiling inside this
person's fucking,
uh,
Olympic size pool.
And also a lot of shit came out about the NFL and that pink jerseys and by a lot
of shit,
I mean,
the website I went to in the one article that I read,
um,
about,
uh,
I thought it was a legitimate website.
I mean,
it was on the Internet,
right?
And they were saying that like,
you know,
like 95% of the profits from those jerseys went into the NFL has pockets.
And I think that people were starting to blow whistles and,
but the NFL makes so much fucking money for media giants,
Espn,
fucking Fox and NBC that they all kind of squashed it.
And I think that the
pink lady and the NFL both made their money and this slowly
backing off each other and just going to pretend it never fucking happen because
this year they went from,
Oh my God,
if I see another fucking pink thing again in my life,
um,
I'm going to kill myself.
Last year you couldn't escape it.
I mean,
I remember when I was in New Orleans working and there was like a,
I went to this casino in the blackjack table.
That was two years ago.
The blackjack table was pink.
It was all fucking over the place.
And now I notice this year straight across the board,
the NFL and everywhere else,
way,
way the fuck
toned down,
way the fuck tone down.
And I think they're all slowly walking away from a some unsavory shit.
They just act like it never happened.
Hey,
you know,
whatever we should like that crimes and misdemeanors was somebody got killed but
nobody got caught.
And you just kind of get over it after a while.
You just get on with your fucking life.
I think if I had to guess,
uh,
but then I'm a negative.
I'm not a negative prick.
I'm a cynical son of a bitch and uh,
I think that that's what happened
Sunday,
that Oprah will make a fucking movie about it.
Right.
The lifetime network.
Some will play the pink lady.
No,
Oprah wouldn't do that.
Right.
That's,
that would make women look bad.
She,
she's not about that.
If there's a guy,
you know what you just say was based on real events and then somehow they would
make the reason why the evil woman at the head of the pink campaign did.
It was because some guy was verbally abusing her or hit on her when she walked
down the street was a couple of none and not in another like non-stories in
standup comedy,
like the,
the fucking outrage.
You know,
back when I was a kid,
when people got outraged,
what they did was when they wanted to find out if people were actually outraged,
they went out in the street and they talk to people.
Now it's like marketed outrage.
So I don't even buy into it.
You know what I mean?
Like A,
this comic,
they did this whole fucking thing.
This woman made a video.
She walked around New York City for 10 fucking hours.
10 hours.
Yeah.
You fucking walk around in public for 10 hours is a good look.
A woman,
somebody going to hit on you,
right.
I would,
they should follow me for 10 hours.
It'd be the exact opposite instead of people hitting on me.
But yeah.
Hey,
hey ma.
And then the end,
I get mugged.
Okay,
Jesus Christ,
bunch of fucking cry babies now.
You know what I love all the fucking clothes she was wearing were made in a
sweatshop somewhere.
So as much as she's having a fucking problem,
people calling out how nicer asses?
There's some crying child that made those jeans that are so wonderfully cupping
her booty cheeks,
you know?
And you know,
I think that's one to grow on.
I don't care.
I think that's some of they just don't,
just a bunch of bullshit.
If you buddy flipping out about,
it's such a lazy God damn story and then you know where they always get started,
some fat fucking bloggers site,
some victim dose makes a fucking video and then they always end up on those
cheese balls sites.
Those list sites that steal six hours of your life.
Top 10 turtles in the Indian Ocean.
All of a sudden,
oh Geez,
I wonder what those look like.
You know,
how the fuck did you end up there?
The top 20 worse plastic surgery nightmares,
the top 100 a porn star blow jobs in the month of March.
I made much as I'm making fun of them,
I obviously,
because I can make fun of him.
I know what the fuck they are,
but um,
I don't,
I'm just
okay.
I know it's,
it's,
I,
I don't think there is any outrage.
I don't,
I think they just,
they just find like two or three fucking people and they just try to magnify it.
Yeah.
Right.
Someone will get upset about anything like this.
Fucking the chick up there in Oregon who had an inoperable brain cancer and
decided that she,
rather than go through it,
just wanted to die.
It was actually reading this story.
She went to Oregon because if you want to die up there,
they let you do it.
Um,
you know,
and the hospitals are like,
wait a minute,
how dare you decide to die?
And we don't make any money off of it.
That God dammit,
this goes against the Lord.
You need to come into our hospitals and lay there and we'll medicate you and
we'll just drag this fucking thing out and uh,
then stick your alive relatives with a six figure bill.
How dare you go around all of that.
Did she basically medically speaking was off the grid.
So she decided to go up there.
It's actually fucking creeping me out.
You know,
she went up there and she picked out the house that she wanted to die in,
which you picked out like a little yellow house and uh,
and then just basically took drugs like I'm dying now.
Do you realize the fucking nerve that that takes?
I couldn't do that as much as like a,
I could,
if you were getting put cement shoes on me and you gave me a cyanide pill,
which is probably a horrific death too.
But uh,
it's nice and quick.
Yeah,
I'd do it.
I'd still have to psych myself up.
You know?
I'm trying to think what prayer I could say to a higher power just in case it
actually exists that would exonerate me from all the fucking horrific shit that
I've done in my life.
Um,
I don't know if I could do that.
What would you rather do?
Would you rather just go to Oregon and Dinah Yellow House,
hanging out with your friends?
Just watch a football game and be like,
all right everybody,
let's man,
I had a great time.
Like you going home.
See you later,
man.
I just fucking pop a pill.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if guys,
I got nothing.
I don't know what the fuck happened this week.
Oh,
I,
here's one for you.
Kansas city,
Kansas city royals lost the world series.
Man that killed me.
I wish they sent that guy home.
You know,
even if he got thrown out at the plate just to have a fucking,
somebody tried to get an inside the park home run in the ninth inning down by
one bottom on the ninth at home.
Jesus Christ.
I was watching that and the bar and um,
the second it went by that guy,
I'm thinking all right,
that's a double.
Then it went down there and he bounced off the wall and that guy kicked it or
something.
I'm like,
that's definitely a trip.
But you know what kills me.
If that was Willie Wilson running the base path,
he definitely would have made it.
Ah,
that fucker would have made it.
He would've made it.
And then you know what you would have had,
you had one of the,
where you would have had one of the great plays in baseball.
However,
if anybody's going to sit around and give that guy shit is like,
you know,
he should've gone and let's say the same reason why he didn't go is why that guy
in center field miss the fucking ball.
Cause it was the ninth inning of the world series.
You know what I mean?
There's so much on the line.
That was the regular season.
That guy just would have let the blooper dropping.
But he ran in thinking,
I got to make a play.
You've got to make a play.
And then the second they hit the ground,
he looked like me out in the field.
You know,
I actually make fun of myself a lot athletically,
like I stink and that nothing could be further from the truth.
A lot of people don't know.
I was actually drafted by the Texas longhorns to play baseball,
but,
uh,
I just decided,
you know,
I mean,
I just,
Roger Clemens was still there at the time and I was just,
you know,
I was just like,
it's his time.
It's his time.
I,
I don't,
I don't want to do that to people.
Right.
Does anybody wants you to hockey at all?
I've been so busy fucking looking at all this other shit.
I haven't had no time to look at whatsoever.
Although I do know
that,
uh,
at the fucking Bruins beat the Senate is the other night,
didn't they?
Three to two and they shifted up the lines.
Bergey's lying there.
They got my shine and the other fucking line or something,
be people I basically out of shit to talk about maybe for the first time ever.
So I'm just going to sit here and uh,
just can you guys just ride with me for the next couple of weeks while I,
well,
I'm going to,
we're going to write and record these next couple episodes and then I'm going to
be done with the F is for family shit.
Then we're going to animate it.
Then I'll actually have some free fucking time and I can actually live a little
bit of life and maybe actually have something to talk about.
Oh my God damn podcasts.
Mike,
what am I up to here?
Like 50 minutes,
51 minutes.
I got to somehow figure it out another nine minutes to shit that I have to talk
about me.
You know what?
You're not going to help me.
He just going to sit over there.
Go.
Oh,
we got another glitch.
Got another glitch in the fucking main board here.
Mike,
has that ever happened?
Any podcast in here?
It is right now.
What does with Megan technology?
It's just,
it just doesn't fucking work out for me.
I know.
All right.
Whatever
corpse found in a Costa Rican Concordia and wreck a soon to be Russell Rebello.
No Way.
Not fucking Russell.
Rebello Oh,
Jesus Christ.
This is my fucking phone.
Who is it?
Great
bump,
bum.
All right,
shit.
I gotta take this guy.
Sorry.
Hello?
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm finishing up my podcast going to call you back in two seconds.
Okay,
cool.
Bye.
This is how bad I am with with technology.
The reason why,
whenever my management calls I always pick up is because I know they probably
sent me an email that I didn't see and I'm supposed to be somewhere that I'm
not.
I really fucking hate the fact that people can get away with now.
You know like,
dude,
why didn't you tell me I sent you an email?
Why don't you just send a fucking carrier pigeon that doesn't fly back to you
and like you should send a parent is what you should do.
Send me the message and then the parent comes back like,
wow,
I was able to give it to him and he read it.
Right?
You just send a fucking email.
Did I just imitate a parrot?
Is that how much I'm fucking struggling to fill time?
Yeah.
I don't fucking like when people do that shit,
they think I sent you an email.
It was all in the email.
It's like,
dude,
I get a thousand fucking Ebo much porno I've watched on,
on,
uh,
on my computer.
Jesus Christ.
You want me fucking emails?
I get a day.
I've Shit.
Yeah.
On all of these fucking websites,
I can't even find emails anymore.
I get so much stuff.
And then people go,
oh,
why didn't you,
why don't you just start a second account?
And yet on that one,
you know,
it's only for friends and family and all of that fucking shift because
eventually I'm going to have an open and I'm going to look at somebody,
uh,
you know,
fucking blow in somebody and then the next scene,
are they good?
They somehow they just get it.
There's no more privacy or whatever.
So that's the reason why I took the phone call.
I apologize.
That was unbelievably,
unbelievably.
It's probably typically I'm professional of me.
Um,
yeah.
So anyways.
All right,
what do I got going on coming up anyways?
I,
you know what,
I'm just going to hype the shit that I do have coming up.
I got stand up special coming up,
uh,
December 5th.
I know I bored you to death with this,
but I'd love if you watched it.
It's on Netflix and I've been getting shit about this,
that it's only on Netflix and that you're not gonna be able to buy it anywhere
for like a year.
And all I have to say is you only have yourselves to blame for that.
All right?
If you cut fucking cunts would actually pay for the goddamn thing.
I could put up my own money for it,
you know,
but I can't put up my own money for it because only like maybe,
I don't know,
5,000 you will actually purchase the thing and that'll get me 25 grand back of
about 180 grants.
So would you do a deal like that?
You wouldn't.
So what happened?
Netflix put up the money.
So that's how it works.
And then part of my agreement is that they own it exclusive for a year.
That's how it works.
But here's the thing,
you know some assholes,
some gonna,
whatever you fucking tech Geeks,
call it,
rip it and wrap it and fucking upload it.
And it's going to be on Youtube anyways,
so you'll just see it that way.
Okay,
so quit breaking my fucking balls about it.
He's fucking nards man.
You out there.
You know how come they just keep making movies about fucking superheroes in,
in a transformers and shit and apes taken over the planet because you stole all
the other ones.
Just stole it.
You stole all the fucking where you get what you pay for,
you stop paying for movies.
So now they're like,
fuck it.
We're gonna make these movies that even if you steal them,
it's going to suck to watch at home.
They're either gonna make,
those are going to make little cheapy little cheapie ones where you got s,
you know,
you've got to share a sleeping bag with the five other actors and the directors
every day on a shoot.
Those are the only fucking movies they make any boy,
and you know what you fucking cut.
It's got no one to blame but yourself.
So I don't want to hear it.
So my special comes out December 5th on Netflix.
All right.
I should have called it.
Uh,
you get,
you get what you pay for.
Oh,
is that what you should've called it bill?
Ooh.
Then what's going to happen?
Highs is some group going to get upset.
Who's the latest guy to get?
Chris rock got in trouble.
He got outraged.
He got some outreach.
He told some jokes and people were outraged.
Some people or some groups.
How long?
You know what's funny about what he did was there's no real group,
I guess Boston strong.
They could get outraged.
They could pretend to be outraged so they could sell more tee shirts.
So then they can align their fucking,
and then,
uh,
you know,
maybe a couple of it trickles down to the actual victims of the bombing.
I swear to God,
like I would like to start at,
you know what the charity you should do is you just walk up to the person who
got injured in the,
in the
bombing and you just hand them a bag of cash that insurance companies can't see.
So they don't say that this,
well,
you're now making this much money.
So this somehow cancels your policy.
We've got to somehow come up with something where you just get the money
directly to the wounded warrior,
directly to the victim of the,
uh,
of the marathon bombings,
you know,
as opposed to these Mary Kay cosmetic fucking cunts who is standing in between
the,
the money in the victim,
like a fucking this sit there like,
oh,
a screen.
I live way up my arms out right now acting the south,
just catching as much of the cash as they possibly can.
It's like a filter.
I don't know.
I'm not saying they're all bad,
but generally speaking,
you know what I mean?
People are fucking people and I,
yeah,
you know,
I don't trust them.
I don't fucking trust them.
Is this bad?
Am I,
you know what's funny is,
uh,
at some point I,
I'm hoping to get to the level in this business that actually somebody will take
the time to get offended by something that I say.
Although the second show last night,
you know,
it was David spade was in the crowd.
I don't want to drop the name and I'm a fucking huge fan of his.
So I wanted to impress him and then I went up there and I fucking ate my balls.
I didn't eat my balls.
I,
he's fucking kills you,
you know?
And that was like the last set of the night.
It was my last sets in La.
It's just lingering there.
So fortunately tonight I'm actually at flappers.
I swear to God,
that's the name of a comedy club.
I don't know why they always have to give him zany names like Xannies,
right.
Wackos,
bananas,
Fuck,
whatever the hell they call them.
This one's called flappers and evidently it's because back in the day,
I dunno,
there was people that,
people who danced you don't like during the Vaudevillian days,
hey,
let's get some flappers out there.
You know why we get the,
you know,
why the comics,
I don't know.
Getting his puppet whenever the fuck they were doing.
Right.
So what I was so they named Miss Comedy called flappers and then all of
waitresses and shit got addressed.
Like it's the 1920s.
And then the guy who runs the room,
he's got a fucking dress,
like he's got a fucking Tommy Gun and a violin case.
I don't know why they do it.
I don't know why they don't sit down with other comedians that have a meeting
and just say,
Hey,
do you think this is a good idea?
Oh,
speaking of which,
you guys got to listen to the Versie effect this week.
Another all things comedy.
A member Paul Versey,
um,
somebody threw a fucking beer bottle at him.
Thank God they missed,
they threw a fucking beer bottle at him.
And first he did said he did some Matrix Shit and uh,
the guy missed him.
But like this is just classic comedy clubs,
security.
Like,
dude,
I don't know if you guys realize,
but,
but throwing a beer bottle,
it's somebody who's fucking head is assault with a deadly weapon.
Like you literally can lose your I cave in your skull.
I had a buddy of mine in high school,
somebody smashed a bottle in his face.
He's scarred for life.
I haven't seen him in years,
but I mean he had this big scar going from his forehead right down the side of
his face.
Totally affected them socially.
Like in when you talk to him,
he would shoot his face to the side.
He was this outgoing guy became all fucking self conscious and all that shit.
Right.
And um,
this guy does this shit.
Classic Comedy Club Security.
Do you know they didn't get the guy's name and he just fucking left.
They're like,
oh,
he just ran out of here.
So what do you mean he just fucking ran out?
How does he just run out?
And he threw a fucking beer bottle at somebody's hi,
just pharaoh.
He kind of slipped through our fingers.
He
fucking ran out the door.
Like Charlie Chaplin.
I'm not saying you got to go fight the guy,
but with all the cell phone camera video that you can get now,
you couldn't video tape his fucking car.
That video tape.
What?
I'm so old,
whatever.
He couldn't get a VHS tape of him.
Him drive it out of the parking lot.
Just something,
a picture of his car,
anything.
That guy should be in fucking jail.
Oh,
sorry.
It's a good friend of mine sent me to a fucking beer bottle on it anyway,
so if you want to listen to the full story of it,
uh,
listen to the verse,
the effect this week.
And um,
that's it.
Mercifully I'm up here at an hour.
I apologize guys.
I had,
uh,
you know,
I didn't get it done this week.
You know,
I think I started off strong with a test pilot.
Shit.
Yeah.
Hi Andy.
I ended up kind of weekly or maybe I did.
Maybe you guys are actually enjoying it and I just can't hear the laughter.
Um,
this weekend if you are in Bob Boston,
Massachusetts,
I am doing a the 20th anniversary.
Three,
believe it or not,
I can't believe it cause I think I was on the second or the third one,
so fucking old.
I am the 20th anniversary of a great charity where the money actually goes to
the people that need it.
Uh,
the Cam Neely,
uh,
the Cam Nealy House comics come home,
the 20th anniversary,
uh,
Dennis leary is kind of hosted,
has always,
he put together this charity with Cam Neely 20 years ago.
You know,
from day one it was a big deal.
I remember the doe the year that we did it,
they actually filmed it for a comedy central and now somehow it is in its 20th
year.
I remember a few years ago was in the 15th year.
I was like,
how the fuck is it 15 years ago,
you know,
it feels like two years ago,
five years ago goes by like two years now at my age.
So it's kind of terrifying.
But anyways,
it's going to be a murderer's row of comedians.
And,
uh,
as far as I know,
I think they're putting me on last,
as I mentioned last week and that,
and that's what you do on that show.
You do not headline you go on last.
So I got to make sure,
uh,
my,
my game is,
uh,
up to snuff.
So,
uh,
I don't get fucking,
I don't get a bunch of shit.
You know,
it's funny,
it was up the wedding I went to this week,
uh,
I hung out with a buddy of mine that was from Boston and
I haven't been around that vibe
that like that much,
that consistently,
it's just the level of defensiveness.
So have we started talking about sneakers
and uh,
we were saying how,
you know,
Oh,
people will stand in line for sneakers and people get beat up and shot over
sneakers and sometimes he's the sneaker heads say by these fucking sneakers.
And then they put them in the back of their closet,
just they can break them out five years later.
So people are like,
Oh fuck,
where did you get those?
And this dude totally fucking Boston.
It's just like,
it's just like,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't get that,
you know,
like my whole life,
like I never been in this shit,
you know,
like I'm not,
I'm not into shit
like really choppy talking.
Like we just having this conversation,
you just kind of jumps in like that.
It would just looking at him like,
what do you mean you're not into anything?
You like to fish?
He's like,
yeah dude,
but I wouldn't like buy a fucking Paul and then stick it in my closet and pull
it out five years.
Oh look at this shit.
Like every fucking thing was like that.
He went up to go a do a drink run and he comes back,
he's like,
yeah dude,
what the fuck's with that bartender?
You know,
I go update or what are you Barb?
And the guy's like,
do you want it neat?
Do you want it on the rocks?
It's like,
dude,
I don't want the fuck that means just put it in a glass.
You know what the fuck.
So anyways,
I want to be performing for people like that next weekend to raise money for
raw.
The Cam Nealy House.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
I'm sorry.
We ended up with a whimper.
He came in like a dope shit.
Ended out like a con.
All right,
that's a podcast for this week.
Uh,
I'm getting new and comfortable to the all things comedy podcast here.
Um,
please go to a all things comedy.com.
Check out all the other web,
uh,
websites,
all the other,
um,
podcasts that we have on there.
And once again,
if you'd like to help us here,
go to [inaudible] dot com and buy a couple of stickers.
You can do it if you want.
If you don't,
who gives a fuck?
Fuck it didn't talk about Halloween.
I got to talk about Halloween real quick.
This is like a comic that will not get off stage.
He's just trying to get the last big laugh.
Mike's over in the corner,
like for fuck sakes.
I've got a life to get on with it.
We finally figured out,
we finally figured out Halloween.
This is the way you do it.
Because last year we did not give out candy because my lovely wife was so
fucking sick of all the high school kids,
and they're precocious cunt kids in the fucking,
uh,
adults that show up and they want candy and they say,
fucked up shit.
This is how you do Halloween.
All right?
The first hour is the best.
It's all little kids,
little cutie pie kids with parents who are excited and a stick.
Kids like first or second Halloween,
the first one,
the first kid that showed up to the door,
he was dressed like a little fireman,
right?
And I'm like,
Oh,
look at you,
a little firemen are you doing?
And I,
you know,
I crouched down and,
uh,
I hold the bowl out to give him the candy and this adorable little kid reaches
in,
grabs one of the candy and then goes to hand it to me how I am like,
no,
you get to keep it.
You get to keep it fucking adorable is right.
Uh,
and then he turns around,
he goes to walk away,
the back of his jackets is ranked.
There's a little rain coats,
said a fire chief.
It was adorable.
Has helped.
But then he stopped was hilarious.
He stopped and he walked back and he reached any,
he grabbed another piece of candy and putting in like he'd got it,
you know,
and then I was thinking,
well that's cute.
Slashes on his way to be in like these country kids that are going to be coming
here in an hour.
So there's an hour of these cute kids and then the next hour you get these
precocious kids,
right.
Who think everything they say is so fucking brilliant and the adults are stupid.
Right.
And these kids come up and as I'm going to give him first kid,
you know,
there's this group of kids and one of them comes up to the door and I'm just
like,
he looked like he was with the grim reaper.
Now my God grim reaper.
And he's like,
Oh,
I'm not the grim reaper.
I'm so Ansel from like either Harry Potter or fucking Lord of the rings.
I don't know what he was supposed to door.
It's just like,
dude,
fuck you.
You look like the grim reaper,
how many houses you're going to go to when they gets grim reaper before you
blame yourself that you made a bad costume,
you little Douche,
right?
So I'm like,
I'm sorry man.
I didn't see the movie.
And he goes,
who could you at least read the book?
I wanted to fucking boot of rightness.
Seventh grade ass or,
and then another group of kids,
they come there and we all fucking give him candy and then they start singing.
We,
she went merry Christmas.
they start Carolyn on my front porch.
Like this is blowing my mind.
Like I'm going to be like,
wait a minute,
what holiday is it?
That's what I can't stand.
It's the fact that they think that they're smarter than you.
This is why it's so great.
I never had kids.
I would've been such a bad parent because I just want to be like,
do you think you really fucking with me right now?
I had water damage on a house.
I have a fucking mortgage.
I have a Goddamn wife.
Do you think right now what you're doing is blowing my mind?
Hi you little fuck.
I just,
I don't know.
And then what we did.
So then we wrote it out through those douchebags cause it's still,
there was some little kids,
cute kids coming up and then what you do is the first fucking kid who looks like
he's pushing a high school age and has that Shitty grin look on his face.
What I should've done was just slammed the door in his face,
said he was too big,
but I didn't cause I don't want anybody fucking with my house.
What you do is you let him,
one guy get you,
you give him the candy and the second he leaves,
that's it.
You blow out the candle and the Pumpkin.
You shut off the porch light.
You just shut it down,
it's over.
He shut out all the lights in your house and you go down into the bowels of your
house or into some closet and you just pour yourself a drink and you'll wait
there for 90 minutes and then it's over.
Do Halloween.
All right,
there you go.
Now that's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you next week.
Thank you for listening.